my name is michael anton i am a lecturer
and research fellow at the hillsdale
college's
washington dc campus across the river
here where we teach
undergraduate students who come in for
one semester to
do an internship in the swamp and then
have their minds cleansed and purified
at their evening courses with hillsdale
faculty who explain to them why they
need to resist maybe some of the allures
that they've
been tempted by during the day and we
also are now uh relatively new
uh granting ma degrees we're teaching
grad students we're teaching mid-career
uh swamp dwellers for lack of a better
term people who live and work here
full-time and want
that extra education they want to learn
some things that they didn't get from
their undergraduate education
but they either can't or or don't want
to
drop out of the workforce for two or
three years
and go off to grad school so we're
making that available to them a
hillsdale education available to them
here
mid-career and focusing on obviously
politics and political people
okay our panel this moment this morning
is entitled the black lives matter
movement and civil rights and we're
going to go
in alphabetical order so our first
speaker is arthur millick
arthur is just became actually the
executive director
of a new center from the claremont
institute which
uh barely exists arthur is it's only i
think
as of now employee he is standing it up
it will be called the center for the
american way of life
uh and it's launching now essentially uh
prior to that arthur was associate
director of the center for american
studies
and the awc family foundation fellow at
the heritage
foundation just across the street from
our hillsdale's
washington dc campus as i'm sure many of
you know
his work there focused on the tradition
of american political thought
and freedom of speech prior to his time
at the heritage foundation arthur worked
at the house committee on armed services
and the hudson institute
he holds a masters from the university
of chicago and a ba from emory
university i'll also say
if i'm incorrect in this arthur can
correct me and i apologize in advance
but of the four people standing before
you today
he's the only one who hasn't been
regularly featured on the tucker carlson
show and in fact i don't think he's ever
been on it at all
actually if you could if you could make
your remarks from the podium and then
we'll do the q a from there sure
well thank you very much everyone for
joining us here and thank you very much
to hillsdale for inviting me it's really
a great honor i should say that i've
long admired hillsdale
i'm not a graduate of hillsdale but i
feel that i graduated in spirit which
mind you is not an accredited degree
now the recent blm organized riots
have been good for business not for the
businesses of course that were torched
looted and forced to close down the
riots were good for blm's bottom
line i've calculated that approximately
10 billion dollars
was given or pledged to blm or black
focused causes
by america's corporations foundations
and individuals
as a result of these riots and protests
most notably bank of america pledged one
billion dollars with a b
over four years to support as they say
economic opportunity initiatives
to combat racial inequality accelerated
by the global pandemic not only are
these breathtaking amounts
but they were given based on three
falsehoods
the first that george floyd was murdered
because of his race
the second that black people are being
systematically murdered
by cops and the third that america
has racism in its very dna the left
learned an important lesson from all of
this
the more they riot the more corporations
pay out
why have there's why has there been so
little corporate resistance to this
only a few have stood up and said this
is a shakedown it's extortion
in the span of three generations
america's most powerful corporations
went from being more or less patriotic
to globalist
to giving money to revolutionary causes
that would ultimately put them out of
business
so what happened both our political
parties
have taken different approaches to
courting america's corporations
the right had an earnest strategy that
spanned for about 30 years until trump
and it was basically giving them
whatever they wanted access to the
world's markets
both to break labor unions and to sell
to adversaries
like china lacks labor lacks border
enforcement allowing illegals into the
country
coupled with high low level and high
level immigration
and of course there were various tax
breaks the right wrongly bet
that they could give away the farm and
in
return produce permanent loyalty and
gratitude
our corporations ended up with all that
the right gave them
and yet they ultimately went left
and i think what the left has done is
far more powerful successful and
interesting
first of all in case you've been asleep
for the past 20 years
you will have noticed that the left has
gained enormous influence over all of
america's
major institutions the press the
bureaucracy
the universities the culture industries
big tech and many fortune 500s
before the left became neoliberal in the
90s its center of gravity was the
working class
and they thought the great evil was
corporate power and money
but the new left which began to emerge
in the 60s and 70s is different
not proletarian revolution but the
liberation of the so-called marginalized
and oppressed
of women gays and blacks became their
goal
and in its mature form today liberation
requires
the punishment of the alleged oppressor
group who still
prevents their identities from
flourishing so they claim
and in case you haven't guessed it the
oppressors are white people
as they say the greatest evil now in
other words
has shifted from money to whiteness
as these ends have changed so too have
corporations become tolerable to the
left
and even useful in fact for the time
being
the identitarian left needs corporate
money and political clout to advance its
goals
and corporations by the way like
this new left more than the old left
they understandably fear
bernie sanders socialism more than blm
bernie wants to heavily tax and regulate
their businesses and personal wealth
and in the short term at least blm wants
to do the shakedown
force race conscious policies but leave
them more or less intact
for now so what is blm
its growth has been nothing short of
amazing it's only seven years old but
it's raking an
enormous dough gaining astonishing moral
power and it's imitated throughout the
world
blm was founded by three women shortly
after the trayvon martin case
and then it grew in national notoriety
after michael brown was shot by the
police
but blm itself is really the tip of the
spear
of an obscure network this is what you
have to keep in mind
you first learn about its hidden side
when you try to donate to it
you can't actually donate to blm
directly only to its partner
organizations
and i think this is by design blm takes
on the organizational
the organizing the rioting the the
threatening
the street theater function there are
the shock troops
the main extortion mechanism meant for
prime time tv
and not being able to donate to blm is
smart
if they get labeled as a terrorist
organization or is a group engaged
in sedition and the case can certainly
be made for that
their assets would be frozen and seized
and since they are not really a legal
entity
but a movement a network the money is
largely
untraceable and yet it's tax deductible
much of those 10 billion dollars pledged
or donated largely go elsewhere
and it's too early to trace it all but
some of the funding on the face of it
goes to good causes
education for historically black
colleges scholarships
help to black only financial
institutions
but another part of the money goes to
fueling the race consultant industry
to bailing out violent protesters and
looters
and people who have assaulted the police
some presumably goes to lobbyists who
will lobby on behalf of blm's
legislative causes
and it may end up going to political
campaigns we simply don't know
but what's most important is the broad
consideration
that all of this is fueling all of this
clout
money is fueling the infrastructure for
this kind of form of rioting protesting
and spreads the moral power of what are
truly revolutionary
goals and doctrines so what are these
doctrines
well blm you guys have probably heard
this expression
blm is anti-racist
and i think that this is you know it it
drapes itself
in very sophisticated jargon this theory
but i think it's actually very simple
and it boils down to
just a few very simple points um
and the way to kind of get to them is
not by going to blm which is very
obscure
about what it means but by turning to a
nationally renowned
new york times bestseller who has the
most prestigious position
at boston university succeeding nobel
laureate
ellie wisel in this position uh and his
name is
ibrahim kendi you guys have probably
heard of him and he
despite all of these honors all this
money is among the marginalized as he
claims
now for him racism means racist
ideas and racist policies that promote
racial inequalities i'm going to try and
break this down very quickly for you
it's actually very simple
so what it means is that all policies or
laws are racist
if they don't lead to complete parity
among groups so for example there must
be complete parity among
racial groups of homeownership of medium
salaries
incomes college and high school
graduation
and also parity in bad things like
arrests
criminal convictions if there are
disparities
among groups in these things that means
there's racism in the system
and so if there's racism in the system
there are two options of what to do
the first is get rid of policies get rid
of laws regulations whatever it might be
that produce these disparate outcomes
so for example get rid of sat scores
get rid of policing get rid of criminal
penalties
get rid of credit scores for mortgage
loans that's the first option
and the second option and this is the
more radical one is that you must
intentionally discriminate these are his
words you must
intentionally discriminate against the
oppressor group
as he says the only remedy to past
present and future discrimination
is discrimination against the oppressor
now of course we have to get rid of
racist ideas
too not just policies this means
boiled down this basically means never
making judgments
of a group's behavior according to the
standards of american civilization
because those standards are merely white
standards so for example
it is racist to say that there is
something wrong with teen pregnancy
the national museum of african american
history and culture recently chimed in
on this note
and announced that things like work
ethic
scientific thinking grammar politeness
being on time i'm basically quoting them
are all actually tools of white
supremacy
regrettably in their hatred of their
alleged oppressors
they constantly mistake things needed
for any free society
like intact families or the rule of law
merely for whiteness that's one of the
main confusions in their mind
oppressors minds who operate on the
basis of these standards
um must be cleansed through bias
training
and hate speech regulations what is
being asked
asked for in this theory is simply
impossible
and it's this the standards of civilized
life
cannot be imposed onto any marginalized
group
but at the same time there must be
perfect statistical parity
among all of these groups it's simply
not possible and if it isn't
already clear corporations have an
obvious role to play here
justice would demand giving jobs to the
marginalized and putting them in high
positions of influence
the transfer this transformation is is
in the midst of taking place
but it's pretty clear that if it
advances these corporations will likely
fail
but behind these theories there's one
very ugly
implication and the implication is this
that the marginalized because of their
marginalization
marginalization are fundamentally
superior
both intellectually and morally to their
oppressors
they're intel they're morally superior
because as candy says
it has been a gift that's a quote it has
been a gift to be marginalized because
it allows him to understand justice who
deserves what
in a way that oppressors simply cannot
he in other words is pure and blameless
morally
and it means fundamental intellectual
superiority
because the pr the oppressor you see
cannot understand
the culture or the psychology of the
marginalized
but the reverse is not true the
marginalized can perfectly understand
the oppressor's white fragility white
superstructures
his cisgenderism and so you see
you may already kind of see this but if
you want to implement these kinds of
theories
these kinds of theories of racial
superiority
racial purity you have to have tyranny
that's there's no other way to achieve
this
and uh it's not even clear but i will
kind of add one thing which is that it's
not even fully clear that these people
believe in these theories
and it may just be that they are really
animated by animus and hatred
now you you may say that these theories
are full of contradictions in a way
they're silly
why have they had such a great degree of
success in imposing themselves
onto well the universities obviously but
corporations in particular
and and there's an answer to that the
blm and the the organizations that are
part of it
have a kind of shakedown structure and
it goes like this
it was perf it was started by al
sharpton in the 80s and 90s but it's
perfected itself since then
and i'll give you the example from
louisville kentucky and this is from one
of their websites they say
first you have to identify the target
businesses kroger kfc
humana then you have to demand that they
issue statements in support of blm
if they don't then you target the ceos
the cfos the c-suite
to force them to do that if they resist
and they may well
they may well resist then you get the
local and national press corps
to deride them as racists you swarm them
on social media
you agitate inside of their companies
with sympathetic employees who in turn
will agitate with the leadership
you target hr departments um all of this
has been perfected and works almost to a
t and these old school
you know libertarian thoughts that you
know ceos are these titans who are
uh free to act in any courageous and
bold way that they want is simply not
true this leverage is very strong
but this isn't all of course there's one
last thing that really
makes this uh possible and that is uh
white guilt the the white guilt
that has been uh issued forth into
society
uh has been imposed through uh the press
through universities onto many
corporations and ceos
is deeply felt and what it basically
means what this doctrine of white guilt
basically means is that
white people the oppressor group is born
with a sin with an original sin
which is privilege but unlike original
sin it can never be expunged
one must perpetually apologize give
more and more grants listen be quiet
uh and uh uh succumb to this this kind
of uh
rule and then there's this other kind of
ceo
that i suspect believes regrettably
that uh the left will probably win over
the long haul
and i might as well tether my wagon with
them and give money to them
that's the other kind of cynical
decision
um i'm running out of time but i want to
propose
a couple of solutions first this has
been
an experiment for the left they wanted
to see
how far they can take white guilt in
destroying
and tearing down america and in a way
they have succeeded
they've learned how to socially engineer
these kinds of situations
and to make good on them next time next
time this comes about
i suspect that there will be if there
isn't pushback there will be
some desire to pass reparations
legislation which they have already
written
which is already prepared to go or to
implement
anti-racism uh federal bureaucracies
around the state
on the state and local level one last
thing to conclude
this doesn't have to be the case
corporations can stand up
they can go to the press and they can
say shakedowns are unamerican
we are being extorted the irs too can
investigate where on earth is all of
this money going
what's it actually being used for and
the president of course
can do a gambit something like this he
can say to the corporations
you have contributed to riots that have
burned down torn down
american cities demand your money back
from blm
and if you don't well you have
contributed to the tearing down of these
american cities
and investigations should look into this
whether you consciously contributed to
this or not
thank you very much
[Applause]
okay our next speaker is wilfred wilfred
riley sorry
associate professor of political science
at kentucky state and the author of the
books
taboo 10 facts you can't talk about hate
crime hoax and the 50 000
question he's currently working on the
upcoming project
alt wrongs an american case against
racial nationalism
nationalism as well as sketching out a
book looking at the transgender gender
fluid and other kin
i can spell that if you need me to it
seems like a neologism if ever i've
heard one
other kitten communities and and the
idea of flexible identity he has
published pieces in academic questions
commentary
quillette and a number of other journals
and magazines and i will just say
to tie this back to my earlier remark i
first became aware of
professor riley's existence and work on
of course the tucker carlson show where
i saw him and was quite impressed by his
analysis and wondered why i didn't know
about him before but now we do and now
you can hear from him directly
[Music]
well good to be here and thank you for
the intro
um i will note as read the upcoming
potential book about flexible identities
as
a social scientist who leans right i've
enjoyed some comments from the earlier
speakers about whether the woke
left in fact is sort of the party of
science in modern american society
and uh looking at my phone getting ready
to prep my speech i see that
facebook and twitter as of today
recognize 58 scientifically distinct
sexes or genders so i don't know if
they're any uh hillsdale biology
faculty in the audience but you may be
able to tell me later on at lunch or
reception whether that's scientifically
accurate or not
i will also note if you are dealing with
white guilt you can a sage that by
buying any of the books just mentioned
um so but in
in all honesty uh the opening joke aside
i'm glad to be here i've worked with bob
woodson on a number of things
i'm an academic myself and a big fan of
the hillsdale model
and i'm talking today about what's
obviously an extraordinarily relevant
topic
which is policing not merely in the
context of the constitution
but of the modern crime environment
especially
esri inner city crime and especially
esri the currently popular
idea of defunding the police
dramatically shrinking police
departments cutting budgets by
most proposals are on the order of 40 to
65 percent
and these are complex topics but my
basic one sentence take on policing is
that it's a good idea
um i the police are not
the police are in general good they're
not
murdering people in mass and any serious
move
toward bulk defunding of law enforcement
is
a silly and dangerous idea
and this last point is not a
hypothetical from me as sort of
center-right political pundit we know
this as a fact because we've tried it
before
um there's a full-length best-selling
book by mona sharon
do-gooders which is really just the best
and one of the most
readable of many uh tackling what
happened when this last occurred
that breaks down how that worked i see a
couple people taking notes that's
do-gooders well worth reading but
between about 1960
and 1974 an incredible number of
well-intentioned
but unfortunate liberalizing changes
were made to the american criminal
justice
system and i attended law school myself
at the university of illinois
but i will say this is the case to an
extent to which most people who are not
themselves leos law enforcement officers
or members of the legal community are
not aware
so we obviously during this period saw
miranda
the famous case requiring the reading of
a right statement
to criminal suspects but we also saw a
lesser-known matter called escobado
which
substantially extended that previous
case
we saw community policing as it's called
where many cops spent their time running
for example baseball leagues rather than
patrolling on foot or in cars we saw the
open defunding of many police
departments
such as newark's we saw lowered average
sentences we saw
mandatory maximum sentences as well as
mandatory minimum sentences
i don't want to get too wonky here but
what's called the fruit of the poison
tree doctrine really took hold around
the same time
this is the idea that if police officers
violate
any technical rule while making an
arrest or preparing a case
it is not the case that the officers are
suspended or fired
but instead any evidence that's been
obtained through this methodology is
tossed out and the defendant very often
a majority of cases goes free this was
famously described by a member of the
supreme court as the criminal being set
loose because the constable has
blundered
so i'll note actually even the idea that
every criminal defendant
must be provided with a free attorney
paid for
by the state is a product of this era
that dates very specifically to the
gideon v wainwright decision
in 1963. um
it's my suspicion that citizens
certainly might want to keep some of
this
gideon for example perhaps miranda in
place
but the combined effect of all of it at
once
like so many of the things that happened
during the era that's misnamed the 60s
so i've heard was predictable
and remarkable between the 1960s and the
1990s crime in the usa
surged about 570 percent overall if
you're looking at the full
set of crimes in every statistical model
i've seen
that's not an exaggeration you can find
u.s crime rates between 1960 and 2018
just by searching logically enough the
phrase u.s crime rates between 1960 and
2018 and but
smart group computer access is broad in
the room i suspect
but between 1963 and 1993 to give out
some of the core statistics here
murders surged from thousand six hundred
forty
to about twenty five thousand uh
perhaps even more disturbingly rape
sexual assaults jumped from seventeen
thousand
to a hundred six thousand um
robberies went from 116 000 to 660
000. and this is again this is in the
modern era when people were reporting
crimes this is from the middle of the
1960s to the middle of the 1990s
and so on down the line for virtually
every
other variety of serious crime
the only thing that stopped this trend
in crime
the new normal for crime really it's a
bit bizarre to describe
something system-wide that lasted 30 to
40 years as a crime wave
was republican and conservative
democratic
mayors and governors probably most
notably mr giuliani in new york
mayor daley in my hometown of chicago
refunding police
using technological tools like compstat
to track criminals
and pulling back as much of what i just
described although a great deal of it
came down from the federal supreme court
level
as they could locally and it worked
i'm not going to run through every
single one of four or five crime stats
again but in terms of the key one
between 1993 and 2013
murders dropped from that high point of
25 000 that i gave
to barely 14 000. new york city alone
was responsible for something like
one-third of that drop
whether or not you like every aspect of
his leadership style or not
under giuliani mayor giuliani times
square in new york city
literally went from live sex shows in
theaters and people dressed up as
cowboys wandering around playing guitars
and asking you for money
to disney reviews and flashing digital
billboards
and this wasn't a one-off coincidence
um since the sample sets that i've
described 1963 and 93 and 2013
every single time we've seen law
enforcement
pull back or lose by law a major police
power
we've seen a spike in crime following
the michael brown riots just recently i
mean we've seen
over the past five years perhaps since
the ferguson riots in 15
it's important to recall the most
sustained wave of rioting in the usa
since the 1960s
this occurred under president obama this
occurred under president trump
but following the michael brown riots
when activists specifically asked cops
to stop what are known as discretionary
stops
and they did murders went back up from
fourteen thousand
to seventeen 17294 inside two years
this was so obvious that even the u.s
mass media had to notice it
and they named the trend the ferguson
effect
we've seen the same thing this year as
law enforcement pulls back
in response to the riots following the
terrible death of george floyd
with police precincts literally burning
in a couple of cities the famous old
third precinct building was set on fire
burnt to the ground in minneapolis
we've seen shootings double again across
entire large neighborhoods of chicago
and new york including the one i used to
live in
the south side of chicago specifically
the englewood and bridgeport regions of
the city
this is literally the most
basic sort of common sense um the more
good cops you have
the less crime you have i'll also add
citing the excellent if sometimes
ignored work of criminologist john lott
the more citizens with legal guns you
have
the less crime you have the more
taxpayers you have fighting crime
in general overall the less crime you
have this isn't rocket surgery
i'll add something controversial and i
did intentionally say rocket surgery and
honor of an old coach who'd been a
military man for many years
um i'll add something controversial to
this that i do personally think
uh in both of these senses that i just
gave
whether you're talking about police
officers or just strong fathers with a
shotgun at home
the hood quote unquote tends to be
under-policed not over-policed
uh we hear constantly that there's
almost a military occupation
of working-class inner-city
neighborhoods this is not true
police tend to go where there is a
surface of crime
and just as white americans dominate
corporate crime
uh the african-american violent crime
rate currently is around 2.5 times
the white violent crime rate this is
simply a fact it can reach 10
to 20 times the white vcr rate as it's
called in some inner city areas
so i checked a couple of days ago and
the murder rate for black males that i
didn't adjust by age or anything else
just black males in baltimore
was around 50 per 100 000 per year
to put that in context that would put
one of our cities
third in the world for violent homicides
so baltimore would fall after el
salvador
venezuela but ahead of afghanistan
somalia bosnia kosovo
and uganda those were specifically the
countries i checked as comparators
but there aren't three times or five
times or ten times
as many cops in baltimore as there are
in chicago or as there are in most
suburbs at least not on any consistent
basis
so this creates a worst of both world
scenario
where honest minority citizens do feel
that they are harassed by the police
because there are slightly more officers
and they're very overworked
and they can i'm sure be harsh but where
there's still a great deal of crime
because there simply aren't enough
police to deal with it
because the crime rate is 10 times the
national normal and that simply can't be
matched by the number of officers on the
ground
and many minority citizens i will note i
mean one of the
great never discussed facts of american
life is the large majority of white
and black and asian american and jewish
american individuals are normal
taxpayers that think very similarly
many minority citizens at some level
know this
gallup recently did a very good-sized
poll of black americans
instead of white liberal quote unquote
allies and
found that 81 of black citizens want as
many or more police in their
neighborhoods and most of these people
have a positive view of the cops that
are already there
the usual counter argument to this and
i've sort of had to include this
in any talk of this kind because it's
been a feature of
media coverage for months if not years
now the usual counter argument to
findings like this is that we are
deluded um the claim
of activists and i think it's fair to
say of much of the u.s mainstream media
is that there's a wave of police murders
essentially
and any black person or other american
who denies this just isn't quote unquote
woke
um just since late may or early june
this year we've seen the police-involved
killings of george floyd
richard brooks hakeem littleton brianna
taylor
most recently ricardo munoz become major
national stories
and the idea that's usually presented is
that this of course is just the visible
tip
of a very very sizable iceberg
but this is almost entirely a false
narrative and it's
important to point this out um first
speaking from a legal perspective many
of these cases are far more complicated
than they sound
uh mr munoz was literally chasing a cop
down the street with a buoy knife when
he was shot
um given that this produced riots and
violence it's difficult to think what
might not
with without being glib i mean that that
is
literally probably the most sympathetic
imaginable police shooting
except perhaps other than mr munoz
chasing an officer down the street with
a gun
but um even the brianna taylor case
while a tragedy
involves police being shot at while
serving a warrant to the correct address
and then returning fire that's the
actual sequence of events there it's
widely detailed and all reports of the
case
but more to the point the cases that we
read about whatever you might think of
them
aren't just the tip of a giant list
i discussed this in one of the books
that was mentioned taboo
very often they are virtually the whole
list
according to the excellent annual
database of police shootings it's called
the counted
maintained by the washington post which
is not a hard
right media outlet the total number of
unarmed african-americans killed by the
police last year was 14
um 1-4 i will note that after some
commentary from myself and others that
was
increased from the previously cited
number of nine
which had been up for about eight or
nine months so between nine and
fifteen uh individuals um if you wonder
if there might be some
something iffy and how they're defining
black i'll note that less than 70
unarmed people overall were shot don't
have the number in front of me but i
believe it was 62.
if you wonder how they're defining
unarmed less than a thousand people were
killed overall
and of 598 of those specifically had a
gun
172 specifically had a knife this is all
listed almost 100 were trying to run
down the officer with a car
and all of this is out of about 60
million
police stops every year so to cut the
stat short there's no epidemic of police
killing people
and there's one thing that's worth
saying here just as a qualitative
personal opinion that also came up
during the covet 19 panel
the mainstream media very very often
basically makes up stories where no
national level
national media worthy narrative exists
no one wants to minimize even one death
but many of these things are not
epidemics that are sweeping the country
we've seen this over the years with
plane crashes for example
young child kidnapping which terrified
virtually
every upper middle class woman in my
circle to the point where they were
walking around small children on leashes
from the late 90s until about three
years ago i don't don't mean to make a
joke out of this but again that's about
a hundred incidents per year
animal attacks don't go in the water
satanism in the daycares
uh and now to a very real extent we're
seeing the same sort of thing with not
only
police killings but with race relations
more broadly
to illustrate this very simply it's
undisputed that
three quarters or so of those killed by
police are not black they're
white or caucasian hispanics a very
valid question to ask is even if we
concede that there's some slight
disproportion here why are those cases
never mentioned
i've asked that question in a dozen
debates i've frankly never heard an
answer
um you don't have to give them a
disproportionate amount of coverage
but why none the one time i looked at
this these cases received between five
and ten percent of all media coverage of
police violence
you can test this yourself just by
googling something like well-known
police shooting
uh the most recent time i did this i
think i found
one hispanic case two white cases in 36
african-american cases
so all in all sort of resolving this
there are some bad cops
sure but it's the sort of coverage i
just described that is how
you get a fantasy narrative of genocide
or race war
in the world's wealthiest and i think
best country
but ordinary taxpayers don't get to live
in narnia or any other fantasy world we
live in mundane reality
and in reality the place where white
criminals burning down black businesses
while chanting black lives matter just
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
we need police and maybe a gun at home
so we don't get robbed
and that really is my presentation in a
sentence i could have saved you guys
some time
but thank you for all that you gave me
all right our next speaker is
robert woodson he's the founder and
president of the woodson center
an influential leader on issues of
poverty alleviation
empowering disadvantaged communities to
become agents of their own uplift
he is a frequent adviser to local state
and federal government officials as well
as business and philanthropic
organizations
his social activism dates back to the
1960s when as a young
civil rights activist he developed and
coordinated national and local community
revitalization programs i think that's
important if you if you follow
bob woodson as i do uh he can tell
you know war stories from that era from
a different perspective than from what
you usually hear
and i think you'll hear that some of
that this morning i hope we will
and i also just want to mention he i'm
sure he doesn't remember this because it
was a long time ago and i was a nobody
still i am relatively speaking to him
and he was somebody but he helped me
in the 90s on a project that i was
working on at a think tank and i can
remember visiting him
i don't know if his office is still
there but at those days he had a
beautiful office in the
corner of connecticut avenue in dupont
circle in one of those buildings shaped
like a triangle and his office was in
the
point of the triangle in this lovely
room and it was wonderful to meet him
and get
get his help back then and it's great to
have him here today
uh thank you thank you so much
there's a prayer that i utter each time
before i speak and i
i shared with you and that is god give
me the strength
to tell and pursue the truth especially
when it's inconvenient to
me because if you want to go someplace
you haven't been you've got to be
willing to do something you haven't done
and dr king said that the highest form
of maturity is the ability to be
self-critical
and i think as conservatives this is a
good time for us to look inside
to find out what course correction that
we can take
to change it will
pointed out the fact that there are 14
unarmed blacks killed by white police
officers
when in fact for every one black is
killed by
unarmed police i mean unarmed
there are 270 that are killed by other
blacks
that is a reality which means that
people are not motivated
to change based upon the facts
facts are perceptions can have much more
of an
impact than facts also what i'd like to
talk about
is strategic interest your strategic
interest
is associated with your strategic
circumstance
for instance about a farmer coming to a
stream
with his mule going to market and the
stream is about
three feet high moving along at 20 miles
an hour and he forces the mule in and it
gets swept a mile down the stream then
he crosses
a year later the farmer comes to the
same crossing same mule
this time the creek is only six inches
and the mule refuses to go in because
the mule had good memory but poor
judgment
you have to understand that your
strategic reaction is in response to
your strategic circumstance in the 60s i
was for
central government intervening in the
marketplace because
blacks did not have the right to vote
and so and that required people with
bayonets coming and reinforcing telling
the states to do
today i am against government
integration because my strategic
circumstance is influenced by my
prestigious
uh my situation is strategic
circumstance
and so i'm against that but as a veteran
of the civil rights movement
i led demonstrations in the 60s
but i left the movement because
the many of the people who suffered and
sacrificed most did not benefit from the
change
because well that you got remember
picketing outside of a pharmaceutical
company and when they hired
nine black phd chemists they said we got
these jobs because we were qualified
when this happened i realized i was in
the wrong struggle when we also
embraced integration
and busing i opposed it i said the
opposite of segregation
is not integration it is desegregation
remember debating a a ph.d
black law professor before the new york
bar association on that issue
and i said that if you we have two
situations school a where there's
all black and it's a presence of
educational excellence and school b
that's integrated where there's
diminished excellence where should we
send our children he says school b i
said there's no debate
but i think that dilemma it was faces
but anyway i left the civil rights
movement when i realized
that a lot of people like poor blacks
were not benefiting from the gains of
the civil rights movement and when the
civil rights leaders
entered democratic politics and began to
run the cities the fact that the federal
government spent
22 trillion dollars on programs
to aid the poor with 70 cents of every
one of those dollars not going to the
poor
but those who served the poor they asked
which problems are
fundable not which are solvable we
created a commodity out of poor people
because those same elected officials
were responsible for dispensing them
funds so we
we have now a classic two out of uh
ten whites with college education works
of government
six out of ten blacks with college it
works for government
so our middle class is anchored in a
second
sector of our economy that requires
their black counterpart to be dependent
so we have created a structure so so now
we have had these
huge expenditures over 50 or 60 years
and and so but now because of those
so-called inequities have increased in
cities
that have been run by in order for those
officials to justify or answer the
question
why if racism were the culprit today
then why are black children
failing in institutions run by their own
people
but to avoid having to address those
kind of
inconvenient questions they point
to institutional racism whatever that
means
that means you white folks got this
magic uh
remote that you point
at a school system run by blacks so to
make sure the leadership miseducates
their children
and so it is important to understand
that
that the reason that that black lives
matter and others
have convinced people against their
perception
that the problems of 70 out of wedlock
births
the high black on black crime rate more
blacks are killed by other blacks in six
months
than were killed in 9 11. we have a 9 11
every six months
but to avoid having to address the the
cause of that we say it's institutional
racism
so that then we don't have to address
the problems within the black community
and why
we are not moving and so uh
and because the problems of outer
wedlock birth for instance
and i don't want to have time to go into
it but it was a conscious policy
of cloud and pivot at columbia
university
where they said if we can just separate
work from income
it will mean fathers are redundant and
therefore
you'll see a school dropout so all of
the problems of
the decline of the family occurred as a
consequence
of not just a policy but the federal
government had to actually come in
and open offices and actively recruit
people into the welfare system
so we have millions coming in in three
years in the 70s into the welfare system
at a time when the unemployment rate in
the black community was only four
percent
and so that's how we have it is a
conscious policy
and so what we're doing at 1776 unites
at the woodson center
is that we're we know that the left is
weaponizing race today
with 1619 and our pushback against that
cannot be
white papers that think tanks discussing
it on fox news
we need a ground game that confronts
their
uh uh a narrative with an alternative
narrative
that not only provides data and and
reports for instance
they are saying that the the uh
the the decline of the family was
related
to institutional slavery that is not
case between 1930 and 1940
when when racism was enshrined in law
we had no political representation the
black marriage rate was higher than any
group in the country
elderly people could walk safely in
those communities without fear being
mugged by their grandchildren
so we at 1776 are presenting this
to deal with the perception that racism
is the cause of the problems today and
we are presenting a whole
array of information and also videos and
curriculum that says when white people
were at their worst blacks were at their
[Applause]
[Music]
best
and therefore there must be so so so
that we have demonstrated by our actions
that we have resilience and we're
talking about slavery we need to talk
about a history of resilience
and so what we're doing again is
at the woodson center in 1776 is not
just present
arguments we must present examples
jesus understood that when the service
of john the baptist came to him said are
you the one
shall we seek another he didn't say
wasn't i born on christmas
here's my resume
here's my birth certificate no
what he did he didn't say anything he
healed in their presence
and said go tell them what you saw
ladies and gentlemen
the conservative movement has got to do
more than just talk about what the left
is doing
we must join with the joseph's of this
world low-income people
in these neighborhoods who are suffering
the consequence
of these race policies they're being
pimped they're being bamboozled they're
being exploited
we need to join in common community with
low-income mothers i'll be meeting with
300 of them who've lost
children not to white police officers
but to
other blacks and they are going to stand
up and demand
that we want more police they are the
voice
in other words what the what the left
does is their moral authority is derived
from saying they are the legitimate
representative of marginalized people
well we need to join with these
so-called marginalized people and give
them the ability to speak for themselves
to say they don't represent us
and therefore what we are seeking at the
woodson center is
to develop an alliance between the
pharaohs the good pharaohs
and the good josephs in our society
as you know in in genesis and i know
we're running out of time
in my book the triumphs of joseph i talk
about what's going to save america
is joseph's uh i mean the good pharaohs
are powerful wealthy people who are able
to see beyond their power and their
wealth
and see something over the horizon
that's troubling them but they're also
able to reach across
racial ethnic and class lines
and empower a 31 year old uneducated
hebrew shepherd
in the pharaoh's prisons and come
together and join in a
partnership to save america
and that's the kind of coalition that we
need to bring together the people
low-income blacks are are the sleeping
giant in america
when we come together and empower them
and we stand together to unite
to push back against 1619 and the
anarchists that are trying to destroy
our nation
the people suffering the problem must be
given in voice
in their own restoration and and uplift
god bless you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay first i want to give the panelists
an opportunity
to make comments or ask questions of one
another and then we will
turn it over to questions from the
audience and we do have
uh students with the microphone so
please wait until you're called on and
get the microphone but first of our
panelists have anything to to add or say
or ask
no okay we can we can go to the audience
then good speeches guys
i can't see any raised hands because the
lights are right in my eyes but i'll
keep looking
uh this student may have found you there
okay
well we've got you've got the microphone
you've seen i guess i'm first oh here we
go good
if we don't have government police in a
community
that doesn't mean we'd have no police
thousands of years of history
looking around the less developed world
today if there's no government police
then you have criminal gangs or militias
vigilante groups
i mean this seems so obvious why isn't
this obvious to everyone
okay i guess is kind of junior man on
the policing question i'll take that one
first that's absolutely correct
um if you want more kyle written houses
in the streets the best way to get that
is to defund and disband the police
what happened in kenosha which again is
about 50 miles perhaps from where i grew
up in chicago
is that a group of essentially armed
left-wing fighters had been
burning buildings i mean there was a
sizable church that had been damaged if
not destroyed a massive used car lot
minority owned like most of the
businesses had been damaged or destroyed
and a bunch of frankly right-wing
militiamen showed up to fight the
left-wing militiamen
i mean you can discuss the motivations
of either side but that's what happened
you had two groups in the streets
and there was a gun battle um to some
extent written house won
but i mean during the shooting that
became famous he was being followed by
down the street by a group of other
males two of whom were armed with
firearms
so yeah the way you get groups of young
guys in the street fighting with guns is
to disband the police i couldn't
agree with that more a very quick
follow-up comment i'm a fan of the movie
gangs of new york
there's a scene that shows what this
would look like where two volunteer fire
and police companies get into a fight
during a fire uh essentially the young
men
in the neighborhoods were the police and
fire squadrons at the time
they show up at the scene of a fire
where there's also criminal felony
theft going on recognize one another
from a bar fight
and take on one another while the fight
goes on and people run out of the
building with bags of valuables
so i prefer professional policing to
that second option
i'd like dr woodson to uh comment on the
role of faith
in in your programs the role of faith is
central
to the restoration and redemption of
individuals in low-income communities
the woodson center has 2
500 grassroots leaders in 39 states of
all racial and ethnic groups
90 of them there they have been
delivered from brokenness in their lives
because of their faith in god that they
have used as
as a foundation and and also what is
important
their lives are are they are the
foundation of their success
are consistent with the founders
principles they don't understand
it and so it so it is it is a
upon the foundation of a virtue of
self-determination
all of the things that black lives
matter say are white
or bourgeois values it is precisely
those bourgeois
values that have helped blacks
transcend slavery jim crow and the
current crisis so
faith is central to everything that our
people do
just recently president trump signed an
executive order
that stopped the use of critical race
theory as a training platform in the
executive branch departments
could you speak to what critical race
theory
is and how it infiltrated
the executive branch departments sure
let me uh try my hand at that uh
critical race theory
uh has to do with the theory that i
tried to lay out in my talk
uh namely that the marginalized are
superior on these two grounds uh
intellectually and morally to their
oppressors
and that all policies that stem from
that insight that realization
must be to correct
the oppressor's illegitimate usurpation
of the moral qualities of the property
of the freedoms of the very souls of the
so-called marginalized so that's the
theory
now you're right that it has crept into
the federal bureaucracy and in a way
that should not be surprising it's it's
alarming it's despair it's it's it's
disappointing but it's not surprising
because
these theories were born in universities
they basically
dominate almost every university in
america
except for hillsdale and a tiny handful
of others
and they have spread through the press
to a an entire industry
that works to do these kinds of
consulting jobs
to teach the oppressor group how
despicable they are
how they must bow down how there are
superiors who ought to
rule them and govern them and tell them
how to think now
regarding this executive order it's a
very good step but regrettably it's
reversible
the next president can very easily
reverse this
and if you really want to do damage to
these kinds of doctrines
you have to do damage to the
universities that relentlessly propagate
this kind of stuff
and it's actually easier to do than
you'd think you can take away federal
research funds
that go from taxpayers to universities
that are spreading these kinds of
doctrines
and who are hiding using that federal
those federal research funds to hide
behind science
so there are actually a lot of creative
things that conservatives can do
but they regrettably haven't thought
about doing them because a lot of
conservatives have been asleep
thinking that this is a problem that
will just take care of itself but
i i think what what bob has said is
correct that
now is a time for activism from
conservatives
in in rooting out these kinds of
problems
how is it that the message of dr martin
luther king
it seems to have gotten buried and i was
wondering if
blm does not want to ascribe to his
message because he is a man of faith
i had had the pleasure of meeting him
and having marched with him
and i think his words are more prophetic
now than ever before we all needed isn't
justice
is i had a dream speech but his letter
from a birmingham jail
he said the greatest stumbling block the
black progress is not the white citizens
council
it's lukewarm acceptance from people of
good will
it's more difficult and to deal with
people
of ill will and so but but dr king's
the content of your character is still
central to what we at the woodson center
and most grassroots leaders in these
communities
are pursuing the problem is they don't
have a voice
because the qualities that make
grassroots martin luther king oriented
people
effective also renders them invisible
because the left does not give them you
know i get invited to speak on the left
but one time
because once we get around the
gatekeepers i remember
taking this message for three hours on
black news network it went out to 12
states for three hours and the host was
hostile to me
and after half an hour arguing well
let's see what the
the listeners think it was seven to one
in support of everything that i was
saying
and so the challenge is how do we get
our message directly to the people the
80 percent of black americans who
recently polled said they
off support the police they are the ones
that we need to reach around these
gatekeepers and give them an
opportunity to speak and act for
themselves
that's when that's how we can change it
great thank you for your talks i wonder
if uh any of you could comment on how
the definition of racism seems to have
changed in modern times where it used to
be
sort of prejudiced against someone on
the basis of their ethnicity or their
skin color
and now it seems to be you can have
unconscious racism
if anything harm someone of of of color
then it was a racist act or a racist
institution could you talk about how you
see
the word racism being used and how that
is maybe different than how it was used
40 years ago
all right i think that that's um that's
a
complex question that has a fairly
simple answer
racism traditionally has been and i'd be
interested to hear what the other two
panelists have to say about this but
racism traditionally has been defined as
a fairly simple human vice you don't
like
other people because of their membership
in a particular racial group
and in the usa in recent years that's
faded
extraordinarily dramatically if you ask
people
black white hispanic american would you
not date an attractive woman for example
of another race
the percentage that say no absolutely
would not that's down under 10
so as that's begun to fade there have
been some questions about the viability
of the organizations frankly that depend
on fighting racism
and perhaps coincidentally you've seen a
change
in the definition of what racism is what
racism means now and i think both the
other panelists have referred to this to
a lot of people
is any disparity kind of getting to the
point the critical race theory
definition
of bigotry is essentially disparity
so the great social scientist tom sol
actually wrote a book responding to this
but the idea of critical theory is that
racism
is inherent in what look like let's say
facially neutral systems for example the
sat exam
and the reason that we know that there
must be
bigotry inherent in these systems is
that different groups perform
differently
in a typical year asians outscore
caucasians whites beat african-americans
african-americans perhaps beat recent
latino immigrants
so on down the line there must be some
kind of prejudice math may perhaps be
racist
um and i'm not i'm not saying this to be
glib at all ibrahim kendi openly argues
this he says that there are only two
options when you look at a gap like this
one you can believe that the group
that's underperforming is
inferior and he means genetically from
my read of his book or two you can
believe that the instrument somehow is
prejudiced
i say there's a third option group b
might have studied less for the test
and when you look i'm not
when you look at white and african
american performances relative to asian
american performances
that's what you find but there's a very
very
intense reluctance as some of your
social scientists have no doubt found
to do this there's a lot of criticism
levied at people who look at for example
how much study time different groups put
in or the role of having a father
present on this kind of thing
but the short answer is bigotry is often
defined now as any disparity
there's a disparity in criminal arrests
so policing is racist
let me just one quick comment i have a
column
in the hill today that addresses that
but i think i can speak for will riley
and we belong to the great high council
of black america
and we have absolved all white people
for their sins of their past
you are absolved job
all of them bob
[Laughter]
this uh one quick line this does
illustrate to some extent how absurd
this is i mean bob woodson and myself
are both
confident black men i teach at a
well-ranked historically black college
so i mean who has the black perspective
would it be myself would it be him
or would it be a left-wing opponent
across from either of us on the debate
stage
or is there perhaps no such thing i'd
like to add
[Applause]
again can i add just one thing uh on
this question of
of the expansion of the definition of
racism
you know it has gone from what my
panelists have said
and it has become diffuse and everywhere
ever pervasive in the entirety of the
system
but this is just an abstraction you have
to ask yourself
where is that system where does it exist
and what they end up saying is well that
it exists in the minds
and in the hearts of the oppressor group
and so
what then needs to happen is there need
to be laws that criminalize hate speech
there need to be various kinds of bias
trainings to get rid of these things
and you know you you walk into this
situation and you ask yourself well huh
the way that the left is organized today
making racism the central facet of what
it does
do they actually want it to disappear
must it continue to go on in perpetuity
an
unsolvable thing so that this whole
infrastructure is kept together
and to take that one step further one
even wonders whether there's a kind of
cynicism
inside of blm leadership namely to rile
up more people to say this is not right
and to blame that
as racism so that that little uh
kind of you know exploitation shakedown
mechanism continues to go on
as america actually becomes less and
less racist
this reminds me of an anecdote for which
i cannot vouch
but it's apt that sometime in the 1950s
some interior agricultural province of
china had a major rat problem and so mao
came up with the enterprising idea that
he would pay the peasantry
for every a bounty on rats after which
point
they started raising rats and
i think we're about out of our out of
time but we have time for one last
question
over here okay um i was wondering if you
could speak to
the role of youth in the conversation
about racism
as often we are still trying to find our
own opinions but may seem
pressed to have an opinion
i couldn't hear the question can you can
you can you repeat the question please
for the panelists
yes how off uh what role
should youth have in the conversation
about racism um
when quite frequently we're still trying
to figure out
our own views
do we just go yeah or whoever you know
whoever has a
thought on that i mean if i can
interpret the question i think there's
this notion
you know a phrase that one did not hear
five years ago
uh but is now everywhere two-word phrase
breaks silence there's this idea that
like you must take a stand
maybe you don't think you have an
opinion on this maybe you think it's
irrelevant to your daily life and your
job
but you have to sign on the dotted line
or we'll identify you as a bad person
and then when somebody who's held out
for a while finally speaks
they are said to have you know they
break silence i i
i assume that's what the questioner is
getting at that dynamic
well if we're just sort of moving down
the table and answering that one i think
there are a couple things first of all i
don't think you have to take a stand
on every single question if you don't
have a strong opinion
i recently asked my students their
opinion on some of the fighting going on
the rioting in the streets and so on and
one kid responded and said
if the situation actually was a neo-nazi
a communist and a legitimately crooked
cop fighting in the streets i would let
them fight and walk on to work
i don't think that's actually the
situation but that's a very legitimate
perspective
you don't always have to pick a side you
can be perfectly free to think that many
movements and society are run by
lunatics and grifters and just go on
with your life
um but with that said my advice if
you're genuinely interested in questions
of race
or feminism or anything like that is to
pretty much read everything
one thing that i'm very thankful of is
that i grew up in a diverse
working class neighborhood away from
kind of the sheltered single perspective
you're supposed to have
um if i went to the thrift store to pick
up some books after practice i mean
i got everything from hockey mod booty
writing for third world press
to people that would now be considered
quote-unquote alt-right peter bremelo
and pat buchanan writing about teachers
unions and the death of the west
military schwarzkopf and colin powell
talking about when war is necessary
and i don't know if i'd put any of these
people in the categories they're
sometimes placed into i'm just saying i
read all these books i disagreed with
some opinions i agreed with some
opinions
um that's what i would recommend i think
that today in many universities there's
sort of a crippling
sort of left of center left ideology
that's the only thing you're supposed to
believe in
and a lot of it's just nonsensically
wrong like when the the quote-unquote
joke was made earlier are there really
58 genders
so if people ask you to believe in
something i guess look at it
go online research read maybe talk to a
faith leader a coach your parents and
see what you actually think
and make your decisions based on the
facts that come in from that that's
really all i can say
all right let me just say that my my
prayer is that white people will
will get to the point where they get
race fatigue
and just get tired of it and on the
other hand i'm thinking about cashing in
on it
that's selling like everybody else i
want to
i want to sell for fifty dollars a
paddle
that guilty self-fledgling
whites can buy for fifty dollars and
whenever they feel this
the surge of white guilt they can give
it to a black right here
didn't you want to sell these on the
1776 website
at 50 maybe maybe low i you know i think
people might be willing
to talk to legal about it reparations
pedal
i'd pay more than 50. i recommend white
guilt cards instead
just you know i didn't know there were
58 genders the last time i had wrote
about that
i think was four years ago it just shows
you how much progress the united states
has made in four years
because when bill de blasio announced
his new
policy for the city of new york i think
in 2016
there were only 32. no one ever asks
what the wage gap is across
all of them
all right well please join me in
thanking our panelists